how do you stop that pawn advancing with
a nasty check black's rooks are also
going to team up and
kind of uh
take away the white remaining pawn yeah
and i suspect that the white king might
be trapped in a little mating net
uh it's not easy actually like you say
the rook has to stay on the second row
because otherwise the black rook will
step forward and give a deadly check on
the second line and so there he has to
play this but look at it
rick and king in each other's way
and magnus has now got four extra pawns
uh white's knight not making a great
impression
still some big big threats actually
black's most simple threat is to drop
the rook down one square to the second
rank give a check trade off a set of
rooks and then use the other rook on the
second rank okay so white's knight now
at least finding a way to defend itself
and this is over it's actually checkmate
next move once the white king moves the
black rook on the third rank is going to
slide across and magnus takes the win
there we go we have a result
all right we have a result the first win
for magnus car